here are three things a dietitian won't  buy at the grocery store unless you want  a dutch oven your partner every night  these are not my idea of a brownie  it may have 50 fewer calories but it is  like more than 50 less delicious of fun  I'll stick with the Canadian classic it  just hits different I don't know about  you guys but I eat food for like actual  energy and there's no energy in whipped  peanut spread listen I'm not demonizing  any of these Foods if they bring you Joy  then amazing you enjoy them but I'm all  about choosing foods that are both sea  cheating and satisfying not just about  choosing the lowest calorie options  possible